previously on grave robbers they're not
that far away
no morning good morning I want to say
yeah oh god no no oh god this could be
bad
so that's an instant death if I didn't
do that right and it's either square and
X or that could have been the two
triggers I'm glad I did not remember
that until now but oh my god my heart's
racing
how is he like okay I might as well
increase my overall health yellow raises
it and refills bullies this could really
get messed up
yeah come on climb over step in the bear
traps Oh dread help oh I have to use a
gold bag oh my god dude you had no
health you had no help you had no hello
it's not talking about blow pass it like
a phoenix from the ashes oh my god there
wasn't any red yeah I know I thought I
was dead dude if I did not use that
yellow earlier to increase my max health
that would've killed me oh yeah yeah
almost died historic occasion what
episode five four and we we survived the
whole thing and we're back that was last
week's highlight reel that looked really
scary Mary you're not Mike we're back
into this is great poppers the show
where we put permadeath in every game
you can die in a game you move on to the
next we're picking back up on resin evil
four and you're standing it from Mike
because Mike is out and we'll be out for
this weekend next week weeks so yeah if
you're new to the show we'll take a look
at our list here just to catch up on and
uh what we do so again if you die in a
game you get one death we move on to
another one
hang in there Mary we'll be fine so far
cry you can see all these games here
we're now on Resident Evil 55 minutes he
you could very well you know if one
thing happens I think you're gonna break
the record oh wow so just survive for
say like five minutes and then we'll be
hitting the hour mark first time
yeah and it's much better than my minute
and 25 seconds with less of us we don't
have to talk about that so let's go back
into it Mary how are you doing you
excited yeah I'm excited I'm extremely
nervous I am I've played Resident Evil's
all of them all the numbered series and
I've beaten resin before but I die a lot
so this is extremely stressful to not be
able to die Erik Green says that if I
make this episode I should get a little
8-bit avatar cute oh you know what I
screwed up I totally forgot about
something so for number eight
yeah that's gonna be hollow night yeah
my bad you let me you let me pick one
that's right I really appreciate because
of course I don't want to play diet I
wouldn't want to either
that's fair right and that's kind of the
name of this show is like you know it's
not necessarily we don't want anyone to
die so if you're really good at Halle
night which I hear you are then let's
let's see you flex your muscles on that
I've beaten that game twice now so I
feel more confident with Halle night
than I do with metal gear especially
that one that one's like insane that is
insane anyway anyways let's get to it
hopefully we do not have to get there
this has a plan do you hear me do you
hear my plan that's here okay my plan is
I don't care about Mike when I return so
if I have to to get through it because
it's not important to me
that is when I leave that is insanely
meta you're messing up Mike in the long
term I know but he gave me this
opportunity and I don't want to die so I
have this giant fish which I heard gives
you health and that's something I hope
so it takes up like eight spaces look at
he's got in every space is full here I
got another golden one egg yeah I got
this little guy here it's enough for
like one egg
I have looks like my health is like
almost completely full or full actually
even plus some so at this stage I want
to be extremely careful and I only want
to like I just want to not die that's my
goal I like don't care
leo says Wow holo night Lal is it
because Halle Knight has this perception
of being it's tothis tough or it too
easy I don't know what he means by that
is it too hard or too easy Leo what does
that mean come on Leo Leo you guys speak
up I don't know because to me
yes Halle Knight is what did you don't I
was a bird that's a bird he has a crow I
think it better not be anything else
because I'm in deep [ __ ] oh god I don't
even know where I am this I do are
really getting thrown into it so just
know that this is going to be very tough
but we're all here
so I can turn around with X I'm actually
relearning the controls and playing
Resident Evil zero right now totally
different control scheme this is unfair
I think I have a knife where's my knife
okay this is a part of the process I
just have to express oh my god
alright I'm so scared one second your
guns gone no do I have to hurt this guy
I do have to fight him I just don't
remember if it's now I felt nothing wait
go back oh he's gone
oh my heart there our boss fights coming
up that are extremely difficult yeah
there's one it's like a water boss right
[ __ ] there's a a big fish it's a big
fish Pro get in like a pond and he's
actually pretty difficult to like take
down some things in the chat here I have
been playing alien isolation I'm still
gonna die in that game for sure I don't
want to check please tell the chat area
so that's that's a good advice so there
are some QuickTime events right so be
ready in in the cutscenes right I forgot
ready for that I guess what are the
rules about like kind of [ __ ] around
in a room and not doing anything to save
time what point do you push me now
have we gotten the five minutes have I
beaten the record no probably not
you're close though just keep going oh
people are saying it's laggy have you
seen that oh is it I wonder if the bit
rate is too high
oh did you local record little laggy
okay
our previews paused I'm gonna stay in
this room until we fix the lag which
also buys me time
everybody wins you guys yeah Eric they
are they are paused but I think I know
try : these Akamai's man you were real
stalling but I can go but I mean if it's
laggy Oh God is it any better now I
would kill an Akamai if you have to I
suppose about to ash I kill an Akamai
don't kill Mike's game Mary Wing listen
we're on the same page here nobody wants
this game to die
Oh God I like I don't even know where I
came from like where am I I think it's
in this room actually that I'm going I
don't know sorry guys hang tight oh god
okay I'm staying in this room then taze
here tables to fix it
if it does you guys should refresh
apologies hang in there chat that's
better don't ruin everything you ruin
everything no one likes you
yeah Isaac you're gonna get blocked you
suck have to plan anything you ruin
everything
no something more specific like whales
like whales I'm actually quite concerned
about the timed events I don't have the
necessary knowledge do am I supposed to
kill the crows Oh coz this was playing
that's why alright Mary okay alright so
I remember I think I'm supposed to
either hit this or encourage idiots to
get caught in it too
sure no do you remember how to duck I
think you're going backwards oh yeah you
totally are okay because that trap was
set off yeah for sure you're going this
way okay great we're learning mm-hmm I
don't know how to dock I feel like I
should learn how to duck oh that's your
knife that's important this sucks
all right so that's the door looks like
oh my god
oh damn it I'm just upset that is not a
crow because that's the whole way I
started in what you're right what
nothing I I know I just I just wanted to
see what's here right I think you're
fine it's a wall no like downstairs yeah
it's a chair okay there's a safe spot
are you sure no I don't know no I'm not
sure about anything I don't I don't know
this game though I'm just saying like I
triggered a cutscene up there in that
hallway normally there's music when [ __ ]
goes down okay nice thank you
where do I put it I don't have room for
this you could move mmm
can you turn items can you turn that
light yeah so you've returned
that green grenade uh-huh and then you
could you could legit fill up every slot
there you go okay here's the thing
I don't feel super-confident AIDS
because you can't kill yourself with
grenades if you don't know how to use
them and I've never thrown a grenade in
a really long time don't use it what
could you check there the table probably
let it lay out that it's gross huh
interesting
that's really good good insight yeah
we've learned a lot today the knife is
on the right side so you are you're sure
oh [ __ ] you
is that a guy with a 1% oh that's a
chainsaw guy chainsaw no these guys are
kind of hard to kill her I know
[Music]
[ __ ] off am I allowed to cuss you worked
here before you know oh he's like that
was my son whoa ballerina well I need
this gun for later you're you're doing
great I really actually need that gun I
want to quit the show we're too far
what's well let's think about it yeah
what do you think you should do so I'm
someone who doesn't know this game all
right what would you do I just know what
I agroed 10 people yeah I'm in deep [ __ ]
I can survive getting hit I can't
survive the chainsaw shotgun I'm sick
okay I only get four shotgun I could
throw a grenade I don't think it'll save
me I'm actually I'm in deep [ __ ]
did I make the record I didn't think
that was gonna happen hey it's okay I
should have hot hit in the house instead
of running forward there's so many
mistakes Mike I'm sorry oh my god I
should have I should have stayed in the
house and lived there for the rest of
the game you were good I [ __ ] up
sorry okay
playing this game we're playing this
other game oh my god that was so
stressful I should have stayed in the
house and like shot them from the house
that's what I learned
oh man I kind of forget how to play this
game how do you die in this game on
master mode you can dive I'm actually a
little nervous
you can die very quickly in this game I
had so much practice playing all those
Knievel's Chad that did not work out I
[Music]
feel so weak that sucks
you set the new record I did not set
[ __ ] at the our records I hid in a room
and died in my first fight skip this
dumb naked boys [ __ ]
oh my bad Knievel teaches me how to play
but I was not prepared for that fight
I don't know how on earth you really got
yourself in a pickle there I ran into
every enemy in the game
surrounding you this seems like a lot
nicer of an experience yeah I think so
these are very different case you never
really see link get his head cut off
like I kind of feel like I have to
escape death at every turn
and this is cute yeah it is a cute game
I am actually I'm very tense about this
game though like I do think I might die
and then you might be playing Halle
Knight oh my god blame the lag
get out of here Chris I
I can't wait to watch you can't blame
anything I just had a panic attack I
think I I mean I totally agree pelipper
like I should have just I shot him and I
think I should have just stayed in that
little ha like tunnel and just kept
shooting from there but I was like I
killed him and then when he came back I
panicked and you can't panic in that
game you know I mean you're not dead
inside high spiral ninja well Mary you
made a real great highlight that sucks
should have gone further than that like
last week no I mean I like I made a
mistake
it's funny everyone says in the office I
don't deserve to be here I just remember
they get so many tutorial props now I
don't need them this is a mushroom
change your damn weapon the next game
wing is hollow Knight
I chose it they let me choose it in the
event of my death
and I chose hollow night because I feel
comfortable that I can survive a little
bit with it God knows right I mean yeah
such a
such a stressful experience that was
stressful extremely alright get in a
battle or something
go fight somebody no I definitely don't
want to fight anyway so so I guess my
plan of attack should be hit up shrines
right like I need to get health if I
want to survive right hey old man
I think fighting people is more
interesting oh don't you do that why
don't you learn me into this I thought
that was the point
no it's survived done better thanks Jess
I uh I see so clearly now not dying is
not how I play games damn cool oh man
I'm I I practice by just jumping in
there and hoping for the best there's a
cobbling right here
[Music]
why I'm like I'm like relearning the
controls this is not good
Oh a sneaky little man huh so you're
just kind of are you like kind of well
Wiener method method inglis like where
you're just like kind of like run from
everything I mean kind of like it's also
on master mode so like enemies
oh okay so like I thought all right like
I don't have tough into the experience
oh for sure and like I also start off
and I don't have any rooms I don't have
anything like I guess so yeah I want the
paraglider ASAP so I have to do all this
tutorial stuff so maybe I'll just I'll
just keep my head down and do that
[Music]
catastrophic asks what enemy do you
think you'd be mortified to die to in
this run probably those jellies like the
most embarrassing yeah the jelly is for
sure I have to get past these guys I
don't want to get in any fight with
anyone
yeah you don't you're not equipped for a
fight what's one hit if I get hit once
I'm like pretty much these dudes I see
you
oh there's one on your left
look at you just running from the world
the other thing I can't do is like in
this game you can yeah I don't think
it's cheating but I can warp anywhere at
any point right now I can't work jeez it
Ron oh no you're tired Oh God
why are you fast this fast
[Music]
thank God he has to stop to swing at you
my stomach hurt I know is this rich life
it's very show is me and I've had a
stomach ache since we started it's too
much pressure I love like playing games
with the idea of not dying it's like I
love like I die all the time that's just
a part par for the course you know he
heard me slip here also you know what
I'm not that much of a badass let's get
this HUD back on
because this has the HUD has like your
audio meter at the bottom there oh I'm
sorry yeah I'm playing so we switch off
yeah I'm not playing anymore that was a
real good five minutes though yeah
if Rob dies I'll play hallow night
that's right
Knievel is really stressful but there's
a different stress with this show
because when I die in Knievel even
though that sucks cuz sometimes I lose a
lot of progress I just keep playing
whereas like on this one like I would
have played that differently in
retrospect like I would have been way
safer I think I just like ran yeah
thinking I could like get away from it
all I mean a real real bad judgment call
there yeah like you can um you're gonna
to climb that right yeah I think I do
huh no no it brings me all the way out
that's right okay you have to climb down
okay so yeah you wanna play really
reserves right like that's the whole
thing is you're not playing that's
really not my style
I mean I'm sure I've learned from this
experience good rune goo so the thing is
you die in hallow night then I play
alien isolation playing yeah that's what
you deserve this is like even though
that was scary when you got chased by
that dude I think like playing a game
like alien isolation with one death is
like probably like gut-wrenching I think
we would need like a paramedic outside
boy I remember when we played that game
in VR oh yeah for sure
if you guys want to see something really
funny there's a there's a video on
GameSpot's YouTube where Rob and
and a couple of our people are wearing
VR and playing alien isolation and it's
just you know Danny plays it too it's
terrifying a bunch of people do yeah
that Chris waters it was really scary
God are you worried about falling yeah
cuz I don't have I just realized I don't
have a paraglider yeah I mean you can
handle you can handle a little guys just
you know I'm just such a vulnerable
little boy you just delicate little
drops please delicate where are you old
man
oh you ever see speedruns of this game I
have I've seen people go like straight
for the main dude you have to get so the
speedruns you have to get past these
four runes and order like a paragraph
glider and stuff like that but you don't
need it to win the game you know the
game will so this is like the grey
plateau you cannot get down without
getting the paragliders I can do the
four rooms and the tutorial and then you
can go head Ganon it's like the only
tutorial the game has but so what's I
know speedrunners will do that and then
they immediately like stasis a rock and
just watch them walk yeah it's really
cool just
like they're supposed to be music here
um I've seen it glitch before maybe it's
for dramatic effect
sloppy noodle haste on inside joke it is
my son though somehow alright okay so
now you have a paraglider now it's
telling me you need to do that I know
that much there's a guardian
alright anxiety already think about the
stupid stupid shrines I don't know which
ones best to go first I think like I
could die in the freakin shrines like
you mean like from fall damage no
there's enemies in there I know you've
got some apples yeah with three hearts
you don't give yourself a lot of
breathing room in this game no it's
easily like one two hits tops
oh there it is I think it depends on the
enemy type
oh man I hope there's none of those like
mechanical laser guys and oh there is
for sure oh that's him that's my guy
he's alive oh that's sneaky now you've
played this game a lot Rob yeah a lot
Eric what will happen if Rob makes it
through this week and next will I come
back and do hollow night no I think when
Mike is back Mike is back I'm only here
I'm only standing in as a real [ __ ] sub
I think when Mike is back Mike is back
but I think I mean who knows but I think
it's very likely that I'll play hollow
night at some point oh damn you might be
right it's reasonable because this game
in this game also you can die like due
to the weather you gotta make you know
hot chilli dishes to stay warm yeah now
it is a good question whether or not
Mike should follow what I requested and
play hollow night on my behalf that
would be cool but I can't force him I
mean so that's the thing is we have to
uh but if I start it then he has to play
it so eventually we got to change the
list so we'll probably get to alien
isolation and do a refresh so yeah if
you guys want to put like any games and
the you think you know are appropriate
for this show put them in the comment
section we have some good ideas like the
division dark zone could be neat that's
like high tents you can do old-school
games to do like gears and that would be
really interesting
yeah gears and so that's other part is
you want to play on like a higher
difficulty if I mean it's something
that's generous chasm there's lots of
platformers that would be really good
for this - like Ori or shovel knight or
something where it's like kind of
pushing you dead space 2 left 4 dead
that's cruel left 4 dead is like
extremely stressful Oh left 4 dead when
I was I don't have the choice
well we'll get some metal gear some
point we're not ditching it just for the
sake of Mary like she doesn't know that
game that well we want to make it you
know again we want to get as far as we
can how far I got with a game I knew
that's how a lot of games you ever play
zombies and then try to pick it up where
you left off and you're at like level 30
I didn't know where I was but it's not
like a lot of excuses it was just like a
thing I think I panicked
it's just as simple as that it's a
straight-up panic town fortnight would
not be a good one oh I knew that was
gonna I knew that was gonna happen
you're alive eat them apples
in those true Me's oh my god did you
break the wall yeah no consequences that
was a stupid moves as leo
very much blows Oh am i doing you think
anything with bombs I think is fairly
stressful there's a lot of so you don't
even have the hand glider like I don't
even wanna get thrown I'm gonna do that
script well you don't need the bonuses
you just need to get through ya ask a
point
you just want to make it to the end here
I'll go for hearts right I guess so yeah
that's the thing is normally I would say
go for stamina always yeah but salmon is
good too because you almost died from
not being able to outrun an enemy that's
right stupid to call Camaro you're just
a little late for resident evil it did
happen
he's like I'm like not even that late to
the show resin evil seven would be good
Resident Evil seven would be really good
to watch Devil May Cry any kind of any
any kind of like smash beat him up would
be pretty cool to watch as well yeah
anything like high action I think would
work out well titanfall we so when we
were testing this game that's what we
did and it was we did the mission in
titanfall you know where you were
between like time did you play the
campaign of timeful - yeah one of the
best campaigns and it's awesome the one
where it's called affecting cause where
you like switch between timelines right
yeah yeah yeah
it would it got real scary because if
you remember that level toward the end
is like when you warp so you're getting
chased by monster an you warp out and
you get to a firefight in the other
timeline you warp back and the monster
still there yeah never really like safe
it was very tense that is stressful yeah
Mike did play doom he it's a bummer like
he got like we again we tested that and
he got really far in the test in the
test like an hour and we ended up
stopping as an episode but unfortunately
I think that's the kind of thing though
we're kind of like what happened to me
like I know what to do but when you have
that pressure on you it's really easy to
get out of line because you don't it's
so final this is so final yeah - just
not even be near a chainsaw guy Crash
Bandicoot that's actually not a bad idea
I do think that game is pretty you died
pretty cool you're supposed to die a lot
of games so that's pretty that would be
rough but I mean the same an alien
isolation like I can't imagine you
playing through that not dying like
you're going to die an alien like that's
kind of the point is that the alien
catches you every now and again right I
was thinking that as well I mean it's I
think that's the point of the show isn't
it I mean if you play you know what
remains of Edith Finch like it's just
like yeah you're just never in any
danger it's not interesting this is a
DLC
cool all tight no can you sell it no oh
limbo could be good yes oh you went for
stamina no not yet so I have to get five
to get three more okay which one did you
put it in ICU oh you can only change in
four four orbs so I have to do four
shrines every time in order to oh god
what is that oh yeah you don't want oh
you're not ready so this guy fires fire
arrows yeah yeah [ __ ] like he'll hit
me from here yeah there Oh God
when I'm like far into the game that guy
like kills me oh yeah
Chris says stop stalling standing in a
hallway for 10 minutes of stalling so
that's the other that's the other thing
about is that in master mode they can
see you from a far greater distance yeah
you got it though no I'm not doing it oh
man I don't you got it a little hop and
a jump
you can practice twice I've died in the
show too falling damage you're egging me
on I can't let it be a third time I'm
not doing it this is what makes or
breaks you it's like every jump you
don't jump you just want to play a
hollow night that's not that's not how
this works I need support don't do don't
let me do tricks
show how close you can get to falling
rock to it vote jump not happening the
chat has said boat now I don't care what
Chad asked to say not right now do a
loop-de-loop you've got this God bleep
stamina so quick you're a delicate
flower I am in a harsh world come on
did you chew
oh that's important you want that okay
good so there's a little bad guy on
those steps there
man I'm so scared to do anything I don't
want to attack them
poor baby Rob slowly chasing in like a
part of me wants to get there's these
things called durians which like Hardy
durians that you cook and it's like you
gang like I don't know I want to say max
max heart so I could I could have a
whole bunch of hearts they're not
permanent but like right they would
protect you in the event of accidentally
bombing yourself
such a slow climber I don't want to
fight anyone
sometimes just gotta keep having a party
party on having a good time telling
stories that's the cutest part about
this game there's like they're all
listening like yeah totally so there I
was hey just call breakout dances
man so the thing is to need fire
protection yeah but I have to cook them
cook it you have to cook it to get the
spicy pet but you get the health no
matter what so it's good for
replenishing your health if you need it
but it's not gonna protect you in cold
cold weather so maybe I'll just book it
maybe I'll book it and just eat yeah you
could do that do it because it takes
time like you you've lost only half a
heart you have six of them and you have
a lot of health
I'm gonna say it half health let's eat
Oh God
I hear that another party okay you need
to eat healthy you're at half another
party there's so many parties rules
popping all right when you're finished
climbing this you need to eat okay I
don't even know why would he better safe
than sorry
get sorry boys over here
[Music]
happy accident says he is going to die
come on I mean yeah I'm going to die for
sure one we all die somehow someway
fave Zelda game I don't know it's it's
it's for me it's like neck and neck with
ocarina of time in this
I think it's ocarina time I think
winwaker is my favorite in terms of just
being visually pleasing and enjoyable a
link to the past is also pretty yeah
pretty wonderful experience for me it's
hard there's so many good ones I don't
even think there's any like bad ones I
can't think of like a low point
oh god wait I think he would have made
it
oh right no another one's not gonna come
I didn't think they'd drop on my damn
hair fair worth it oh and now you got a
good weapon no more sticks for you
that's right literally it just sticks
all right great job so here's a question
yeah if I fell off in a shrine or died
in a shrine does that count
I think any death is a death but it's
not uh-huh no no I wouldn't count so
it's not if I fell if I fell and there's
no game over screen like this game like
what constitutes as the death is a game
over screen and so I'm saying I think
chat can agree with that like you died
or says game over yeah you if you fall
you just lose a little health so I don't
think it counts if you die in a shrine
though like for a bomb or something you
get a game over screen then I think that
counts
yeah okay yeah it's game over screen
which would be it makes us yeah
all right so two more a skeleton guy
just popped on the ground oh I ain't
gonna see him why um he's gonna run like
hell I'm just gonna run so I'll go oh
you're fast traveling yeah so where's
the other the other one is I know
there's one up here you've got good
memory of this game yeah I do I can't
think about I can't think where the
other one is where's mom I don't know
where your mom is
[Laughter]
Pilates it's kind of weird he's asking
you though
[Laughter]
all right so how many shrines have you
got - and you got to get to four right
yeah I get four so you may even call it
after getting the other two shrines and
I could get streams I don't know the
other ones are they oh I think that's
one that's one there's one more up here
it's it's in the snow so I think I'll go
there yeah it's just like again like the
stamina is so important though like I
guess I would get health all right
what's the easiest way to get there
looks like there's a bridge how is it
broken
it's totally there yeah you have to use
magnesia I have to go to this one first
yeah I mean I can get over there go
around this way alright so well Warthog
over there
I'll just work here that makes sense
there's chests behind the waterfall
that's good now I'm sure there is yeah
for those of you joining us this is
great poppers where we put perma death
in every game if you die in a game you
move on to the next right now we're on
breath a wild next the list is not quite
up to date it's not metal gear we're
gonna put save a flare it's gonna be
hollow Knight if I die in this game go
to hollow night and it's me again and
it's you oh man you're everywhere I mean
after like text Mike it'd be switch
we're gonna play hollow knight on switch
that's good yes that was my second
playthrough on switch it's so good I
haven't been the best game I've played
in years yeah so good even like with my
efforts in that I think it will be very
stressful to play without being able to
die because of course like you died in
that game yeah
so it's concerning but that's the point
and the tough part too is like you need
you need to kill damn it you need to
kill people in order to get help right
like you can't just like leave a battle
or she threw my friend's head at me kill
you and you took their weapon they are
embarrassed
please be switch pants oh yeah it's like
if you listen in the wind you can hear
Mike shouting I mean he trained me
there's only so much I can do man that
was so funny I came back five minutes
that's how it goes that's how it goes
it's too stressful I'm not built for it
like this kind of show I'm the ultimate
Panicker
yeah you senpai will be disappointed
yeah this is on master mode skip skip
skip skip skip Mike will have something
to say about it for sure I'm not gonna
get out of this unscathed hey it's his
fault for leaving the office and working
in New York you guys invited me I think
you were the best choice [ __ ] thank you
sorry it's 300 lashes Chad that seems a
bit extreme yeah they're definitely
guardians can you just hit them with
that block dick
those guys are tough no you're not so
steamy yet is my workout your weapon is
your magneto mode
yeah this is it right here okay who's
doing that who's that pause our link
actually sounds yeah that's why they
don't let him talk in these games cuz he
would sound like
[Music]
[Music]
give Mary a second chance doesn't work
like that does not I think that's the
whole point is that I I have to live
with my failure for this whole hour I
have a whole hour to think about what I
did
yeah you definitely think about it like
Mike's like I think I've replaced my
anxiety with like sadness I was really
stressed out and I'm not stressed out
anymore I just feel bad
I don't know how was a real [ __ ]
situation like I you know I bet the
record would show that I edged you on to
sprint and like maybe you shouldn't have
I feel like I was saying just run I
shouldn't hit in the house I should have
like we nerd out and I didn't because I
like I don't know we could think about
it forever
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a good question Xavier so it
doesn't count like warm up well we would
be so that's we're like so I died in the
Last of Us in a minute in 25 seconds
very embarrassing you would want to
spend time on your own and warm up but
not on the stream when when we're
streaming and we're doing it no excuses
one day text him and say I died yeah
we're playing on master mode you can
always tell in the bottom left there's a
Triforce symbol tied in five minutes I
just sent Mike oh you know how Maddie
isn't me I'm sure he's not that mad
you haven't hung out with Mike then
definitely Oh God
do you think he felt it like he's
somewhere in a plane and you just went
walking down the streets of New York
like what is that
hi unicorn but it's like order 66 from
Star Wars but all the Jedi died deaf oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I do need a beer Erik it's been a day
oh yeah you definitely needed this yeah
this water is cold yeah what happens if
you fall in the water you seriously like
you die pretty quickly really yeah like
I mean I I have some time but like I
would probably exhaust all my health
good oh I forgot about the fact that
you're in the cold yeah you got this
it's like a little baby jump shut up
where your horn away not important
shut up electric you're tagged Danny
there will not be Knievel this weekend
because Mike is out of town for two
weeks we were planning on maybe like
recording in advance and we just
couldn't make it work so I will be as
soon as he comes back into town we're
gonna do some stuff but I do think I
have to talk to you about it I have like
something because we've been doing so
many episodes of Knievel I've been like
working on a video so maybe I'll give
that to you guys yeah
like as a highlight right a highlight
because we've done 99 episodes which is
really cool so I thought maybe we could
do something too I don't know
celebrate what's yo alright you have one
heart you should probably eat food
you're fine because I think those
you just need to get to the shrine Oh
God it sounded like Navi
it's like a dream hey ballsy move
husband you know your balls were
rewarded balls were rolling that sucks
well you just have to cheese it like you
did before just Wiener strats the whole
way you're not a brave man I don't know
if I can do any wiener strats here
that's pretty funny coming I just read
that Javier say Rob Mike will call you
to say dude I just had the weirdest
dream Mary played my Resident Evil 4
game and she died like no good thing it
was just a dream about that it wasn't a
dream I don't even know if he's in a
different time zone or he could even be
in a plane I don't know so I don't know
if he's like he's gonna you to York
office I should be Gibby's probably dig
around are you gonna kill him with ice
what's your plan
yep use your eyes
just lots later get that chest fall Mike
can't have revenge
I just died there's nothing he can do to
me it's the perfect crime he invited me
and I died yeah I don't want to fall I
can't die again I understand I did it
you saw the far cry one and then I did
it again inhale oh you you died from
falling damage inhale oh yeah I like my
shield were down I was trying to get
away from the situation it was like just
the perfect death in a way like I saw
the one in Far Cry and that was a bummer
because I think there was like an eagle
distract me which is really distracting
yeah have an eagle come after you like
that man the artistic direction in this
game is so good I know it's really
separate but I just have to say they do
such a fantastic job making everything
look just stunning they have such a good
art style in this game
mm-hm something's up with this old man
what's going on you weird old man okay
so uh I'll get that paraglider and then
we'll probably call it okay does this
mean that you start next episode yeah
nice it's way less stress now I just
need to watch you you'd be surprised
I mean like I watching you play I was
getting stressed and like it goes both
ways like especially when I don't know
the game like when he was playing Dark
Souls he was like cuz he's familiar with
it he was like you know rolling into
like hidden areas that look like oh look
like it would like you would drop and I
would freak out like there are certain
games that are more stressful than
others I think playing Dark Souls
without being able to die there was a
guy on twitch who played an entire dark
souls run without dying and he did it
but I think there's a I'll have to find
it and send it to you but there's like
he's decently far and he dies and it's
just such a gut punch to have him get
that far
and have him like basically have to toss
it aside cuz he and it was something he
couldn't control I think was like
lightning hit him yeah it's just really
unfortunate like I wouldn't want to play
that game without dying
[Laughter]
there's one in your resurrection oh yeah
that's right and that's like such a
weird one because like a little Korra
like crawled up in with your dead body
and was like why didn't marry start a
new game instead of carrying on for Mike
wing you must be a little late to the
episode I did carry on Mike's episode
and I died yeah that's what really threw
you off like you were gone farther he
got the Rose I started from the
beginning I would know the controls I
forgot a lot of the controls like do you
remember when I paused because I was
stressed out when I came back from the
pause I forgot how to run run was ex
I was hitting the wrong button to run
some big idiot use your bombs where did
he go okay good that's good what are you
looking for all right I guess no crime I
guess I'll just put this into heart it's
up to you I think stamina is valuable
too so you can run away from people when
they come to kill you they're both
they're both important
you've almost died twice from not having
enough stamina and you've almost died
you almost died once from not having of
heart so they're both they're both tough
Xavier says if you're a Knievel fan
you'll know that Mike tries to kill me
just for fun so that is true this one
time in a Resident Evil game there was a
counter going down and he was like you
need to push a button on the wall and so
I spent like 20 seconds looking for a
button on a wall there was no button and
then I just exploded for 20 seconds I
was like where's the button he's like
you gotta find it it's funny he's like
certain things in this game like mmm
spending so long trying to climb this
whole damn Tower right yeah and then
there's a freaking ladder never forget
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's like good for you there's not a
lot of it from him so b54 follows
calamity Ganon's truth no wait you
really want to listen to I waiting for a
hundred years to tell you the [ __ ] don't
skip these goddamn kids they just want
paragliders just wanted shield syrup and
paraglide i think man the game will be a
lot more progressive now that you'll
have this yeah a load has been lifted
from the shoulders cuz like falling was
like I know I don't worry about it man I
just want a paraglide I think that's
important too because being able to kill
people from afar is really good when
you're not trying to die oh all right
get out there all right we're on pair
credit breaks yeah all right well let's
get to the end of edge of this area okay
so I wonder like what's ultimately the
purpose is to beat Ganon right so he in
this run I what would be the next step
just to get shrines I think right yeah
because you don't want to die ever you
want to increase your health and stamina
yeah you have such a long journey ahead
of you or like would it be or should I
get like armor first you know I know but
that's breakable armor is not breakable
oh I see reason I got no protection like
I could you meant like oh right your
clothes yeah I think you meant like a
shield um love to think about it that's
gonna do it all right
well you know
not everything goes according to plan no
sometimes you get chainsaw out of the
dome that's gonna do it we're at breath
of the wild if I die next week we'll be
hollow night and Mary will pick up yeah
we got it
we'll go wrong I think we'll go wrong
ever the perfect stream hey at least you
didn't last a minute and 25 seconds like
I did what which one which game that was
last of us I died 25 seconds it was the
first guy and I didn't know that the
prompts were gone in the grounded mode
so I went up to like a sneak attack him
and just ran into a music what the hell
and then they all just killed me I
didn't kill anybody but you know you win
some you lose some
you kind of know you did kill someone
you killed that you killed a guy with we
call it sniper rifle he had like I
thought I thought I killed the chainsaw
guy that's why I was like running cuz I
was like I already killed him and then
when he came out I was like [ __ ] panic
anyway let's not dwell uh we're fine
I'll pass well if you missed it stay
tuned the next week we'll have a
highlight reel of that I'll just run
that probably five times when you watch
it yeah well thank you Mary for coming
in and film me Wow I had a real great
time it's very fun Mike's gonna be real
impressed with my work
he didn't message me back but I'll let
you know when he does good stuff well
thank you guys for watching have a great
rest of the week and yes again next week
see you next week bye
[Music]